an artificial island that rises with the
sea and this is not what you think it is
Vsauce Kevin here this is fine
several of these creatures referred to
as blind snakes were recently discovered
in Brazil engineers found the meter-long
creature after draining a hydroelectric
dam spanning a river connected to the
Amazon biologists say that despite
looking like snakes they actually aren't
even reptiles and are more closely
related to salamanders and frogs
researchers at Carnegie Mellon created a
snake robot these modular snakes can
navigate a variety of terrain from poles
to networks of pipes allowing it access
to locations that people and machinery
otherwise cannot use cat tunnels sofa if
you want to interact with plants there's
Botanica interact ACCA's the sensing
technology treats plants as an
electrical circuit so each different
type of plant creates unique interactive
properties
the idea is to stretch the limits of
what we can interact with using police
composite sketch software and
descriptions from Bram Stoker's Dracula
this is what it says Count Dracula looks
like now meets stompy the giant rideable
walking robot this open-source 18 foot
wide 4,000 pounds six legged hydraulic
robot is currently in development by
project hexapod and if they raise enough
money they hope to build an entire zoo
of giant rideable robot identifying
pastries in a second is this new
point-of-sale system in Tokyo it
recognizes shapes and colors to identify
baked goods allowing cashiers unfamiliar
with the products to still quickly ring
up items and they say the system could
eventually be used to distinguish
vegetables and medicine I'm a moth and
Here I am I'm a moth and now I'm a tree
instantly deodorizing dirty diapers is
this activated charcoal system the
material is called mesopore activated
charcoal which has larger pores than
normal charcoal to absorb a variety of
odors and is currently developed for
hospitals but they're working on a
model finally future forms of life is a
short film based on salience ins kinetic
sculptures
I'm gonna leave you with fire breathing
at 2,000 frames per second and as always
thanks for watching
you